Wegen eines Großbrandes in einer Telekom-Vermittlungsstelle ist dieser Anschluss bis auf weiteres nicht erreichbar. Rufnummern werden so weit möglich ersatzgeschaltet.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabenummer 42, die magische Nummer. Und für die magische Zahl auch ein schönes Thema. Heute geht es um Mobiltelefone und zwar ganz besonders um offene Mobiltelefone. Wir stellen das OpenMoko-Telefonprojekt vor und gleich geht's los. Willkommen zurück beim Chaosradio Express. Ich sag Hallo zu Harald. Hallo. Harald, Harald Welte, vielen von euch auch bekannt vom Chaosradio. Wir hatten auch schon eine oder zwei Sendungen schon zusammen gemacht. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. GPL war das letzte Mal das Thema. Diesmal soll es allerdings um was ganz anderes gehen. Du bist ja in einer ganzen Menge Projekten involviert, aber ich glaube keins hat dir so viel Arbeit abgerungen in letzter Zeit wie das, worum es heute gehen soll, nämlich das OpenMoko-Projekt. Kannst du mal kurz erläutern, worum es bei OpenMoko geht und auch, was deine Rolle dabei ist?
Ja, OpenMoko ist das Projekt, das sich auf die Fahne geschrieben hat, das erste völlig offene im Sinne von offene, standardsfrei Software-Projekt für Smartphones im GSM-Bereich zu sein. Das heißt, wir haben als Ziel, Software zu entwickeln, die vollständig unter der GPL oder anderen freien Softwarelizenzen steht und mit der man ein Smartphone betreiben kann und jedermann Erweiterungen schreiben kann und so weiter, wie man das bei freier Software gewöhnt ist.
Das heißt, im Prinzip ist es was komplett Neues, weil alle Telefone heutzutage gibt es überhaupt ein Telefon mit irgendeiner freien Software drauf?
Na, es gibt durchaus eine ganze Menge an Telefonen, auf denen Linux als Epozitsystemkernel läuft und dann auch unter Umständen andere, freie Software, also sagen wir mal C-Library oder Ähnliches. Allerdings werden die Telefone, sieht man ja, sehr stark beschränkt von den Mobilfunk-Herstellern in Zusammenarbeit mit den Mobilfunk-Operatoren, das heißt, nur weil irgendwo ein Linux-Kernel auf einem Telefon läuft, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass man da auch frei dafür und einfach Anwendungen entwickeln könnte oder dass man jetzt selber wirklich neue Software auf installieren könnte, so leicht. Und das Problem beschäftigt mich schon sehr eng. Ich habe vor, ich glaube, zwei Jahren mittlerweile angefangen, das sogenannte Open-ECX-Projekt zu starten. Und ECX ist eine dieser proprietären Linux-basierenden Telefonie-Plattformen auf Motorola-Smartphones. Und das war also mein erster Kontakt mit Linux-basierenden Smartphones, wo ich also genau diese schmerzlichen Erfahrungen machen musste als Software-Entwickler. Ich habe ein Telefon, auf dem eigentlich Linux ist, aber trotzdem kann ich immer noch keine eigene Software dafür schreiben oder die bestehende verändern. Und dann hat sich das glücklicherweise ergeben, dass der Gründer dieses Open-Moko-Projekts, Sean, heißt er, auf mich zukam und meinte, da willst du nicht mal lieber irgendwie deine Zeit in was hineinstecken, sozusagen mit Unterstützung des Herstellers statt gegen den Hersteller.
Wann war das?
Das war im Juli letzten Jahres.
Okay, also alles noch ein relativ frisches Projekt. Juli 2006. Und dann? Was ist dann passiert?
Ja, die Ausgangssituation war eben, dass Sean der Produktmanager bei FIC, First International Computer, ist. Das ist ein, kann man sagen, Elektronikkonzern in Taiwan, also in der Ebene wie Asus oder Gigabyte oder andere Firmen dort, die hauptsächlich im OEM-ODM-Business sind, also Geräte herstellen, wo nicht ihr Name drauf steht.
Mainboards bauen, im Prinzip generische PCs, wo dann andere ihren Namen draufballern und das dann auch viel passiert.
Genau, FIC macht im Moment, so weit ich weiß, sehr viele Navigationsgeräte und Laptops. Und Telefone auch, allerdings bisher nur sogenannte Feature-Phones. Das heißt also herkömmliche Telefone, die jetzt nicht mit einer großen fetten CPU kommen und Betriebssystemen und anständigen Display und Anwendungen und so.
Das heißt, da steht auch wirklich ein relativ starkes, großes Unternehmen dahinter. Wie groß muss man sich so FIC vorstellen? Das ist kein kleines Unternehmen, oder?
Nein, ich bin niemand, der mit der Businessseite irgendwie sehr viel zu tun hat. Ich habe jetzt keine Zahlen im Kopf, allerdings kann ich einfach auf die FIC-Webseite schauen. Man muss aber bedenken, dass denen zum Beispiel ein Mobilfunk-Anbieter in Taiwan gehört und eine Bank haben die auch noch irgendwie im Konzern mit drin. Also das ist schon ein größerer Verein.
Und die sind jetzt auch quasi mit der Technik durchaus vertraut. Also das ist ja schon gesagt, Mainboards bauen sie, also im Prinzip sind sie in der Lage, ein PC zu bauen. Und das ist ja im Prinzip die Grundlage auch. Da werden wir gleich noch mal drauf eingehen. Aber sie bauen auch Telefone. Das heißt, auch ein GSM-Telefon ist für sie nichts Neues. Was ist jetzt das Interesse von FIC, daran so ein offenes Projekt zu unterstützen?
Na, da kann ich jetzt letztendlich nur Mut maßen. Da müsste man jetzt FIC selber fragen. Ich bin ja nicht angestellt, sondern nur externer Freelancer sozusagen bei dem Projekt. Ich denke, es geht einfach um Differenzierung gegenüber den restlichen Marktwettbewerbern. Hardware, Telefone kann jeder in Taiwan bauen oder in China. Und Windows Mobile hat auch jeder im Angebot oder Ähnliches. Und hier mal ganz radikal einen Schritt in eine andere Richtung zu gehen und zu sagen, wir haben etwas, was andere nicht haben, ist vielleicht mal eine interessante Strategie, auch neue Märkte zu erreichen.
Das heißt, wir müssen vielleicht noch mal klar von vornherein unterscheiden. OpenMoko ist der Projektname für die Software, die auf diesem Telefon laufen soll. Das ist richtig. Oder auch die Spezifikation des Telefons als solcher. Aber es handelt sich nicht um das Telefon selbst.
Das ist richtig. OpenMoko ist zum einen, es gibt eine Firma, die heißt OpenMoko Incorporated. Das ist so die rechtliche, also die juristische Person, die hinter dem Softwareprojekt steht. Und dann heißt OpenMoko zum anderen, quasi eine Art Linux-Distribution für Mobiltelefone, kann man sich das vorstellen. Wobei das erste Telefon, das unterstützt wird, und für die natürlich das auch geschrieben wird zunächst, ist eben von FIC das sogenannte Neo1973-Telefon. Und das heißt, die Hard- und Softwareentwicklung greifen da Hand in Hand ineinander. Und es wird sowohl von FIC auch Nachfolgetelefone natürlich geben, weitere Modelle in der Roadmap, aber auch sind wir aktiv in Gesprächen mit anderen Hardware-Herstellern, um sozusagen die Hardware-Basis für unsere OpenMoko-Software zu verbreitern und auch andere Hardware-Hersteller mit zu unterstützen.
Das heißt, du rechnest auch schon damit, dass da noch mehr auf den Zug aufspringen. Zeichnet sich das schon ab?
Das Interesse ist in jedem Fall da von mehreren Seiten, also auch ganz großen Namen. Da kann ich jetzt natürlich leider keine Namen nennen, aber es sind auf jeden Fall sehr viel Interesse, sehr viele Gespräche da. Inwiefern sich das dann tatsächlich auch oben setzt, steht im Moment noch in den Sternen. Aber es ist in jedem Fall das Ziel und es ist auch absehbar, dass das passiert.
Jetzt ist es ja bei der Hardware, ich stecke da selber nicht so drin, aber ich habe häufig gehört, dass in den Telefonen dann auch das Problem besteht, dass man eben für die Chips, die dort verwendet werden, insbesondere für den GSM-Teil, auch gar nicht so die Spezifikation so ohne weiteres bekommt. Ist das jetzt ein Problem gewesen, überhaupt eine offene Hardware-Architektur zu bauen?
Ja, na ja, das... Ja, kann man nur mit einem klaren und deutlichen Ja beantworten. Also prinzipiell, technisch gesehen, ist das eigentlich kein so großes Problem, weil die ganzen... Also wenn man sich den Telefoniemarkt anschaut, dann differenziert sich der einmal in sogenannte Feature-Forns. Das sind so die Kamera- und Musiktelefone oder halt die klassischen Telefone, sag ich mal, und auf der anderen Seite die Smartphones. Smartphones sind eben die Telefone, wo irgendein höheres Betriebssystem läuft, also beispielsweise jetzt Windows-Mobile oder eben auch Linux-basierte Betriebssysteme. Und bei den Smartphones ist es so, dass da sowieso zwei... Also es sind eigentlich zwei Welten. Also was definiert ein Smartphone, kann man das kurz zusammenfassen als, naja, das ist ein traditionelles Telefon mit einem PDA auf einer Platine in einem Geräuse. Das heißt, man nimmt einen ganz normalen PDA, also irgendwie so was wie einen iPod oder Ähnliches, und klebt da ein Telefon nebenan auf die gleiche Platine und verbindet das Ganze miteinander. Und dann hat man sozusagen...
Dann ist es smart.
Genau, dann ist es auf einmal smart geworden. Und das heißt aber auch, dass dann letztendlich dieser ganze Telefon-Teil, das hat seinen eigenen Prozessor, meistens eine normale CPU, so ein ARM7 und noch einen DSP, einen digitalen Signalprozessor daneben und dann diese ganzen Funk-Peripherie-Komponenten. Und dann gibt es irgendwo einen Serienport oder USB oder irgendeine Art von Schnittstelle. Und über die kommuniziert dann der eigentliche PDA-Teil, sag ich jetzt mal, mit dem Mobilfunk-Teil. Und demnach kann man also schon diesen PDA-Teil, der ja im Wesentlichen irgendein Mobile-Prozessor ist, mit entsprechendem RAM, Flash, irgendwelcher Massenspeichergeräte und dem Display, den kann man ja völlig unabhängig programmieren von dem Telefonteil. Und das einzige, wo man jetzt eben ran muss, ist dann, wie sieht dieses Interface aus zwischen diesen beiden Welten. Und da gibt es erfreulicherweise eben einen Standard, der das GSM-Forum oder mittlerweile heißt es 3GPP. Und das ist also eine Serie von Standards, zum Beispiel GSM 07.07 und 07.10 und so kryptische Nummern. Und diese Standards sind öffentlich und kostenloser Unterlager aus dem Netz. Das heißt, wie diese Protokolle aussehen, ist Hersteller unabhängig und offen dokumentiert.
Das sind jetzt Standards, um mit was genau zu kommunizieren? Also mit einem GSM-Chip oder einem?
Modem, würde man sagen. GSM-Modem. Das sind auch tatsächlich Artekum-Modulen.
Und ist das auch der Level an Zugriff, den man haben will an der Stelle? Also kommt man da auch so an den rohen Datenstrom, der so über das Netz fliegt, dann damit ran?
An den kommt man natürlich nicht ran. Also das ist ein Interface, was auf einem sehr hohen Level angesiedelt ist. Natürlich gibt es von den unterschiedlichen Herstellern der Chipsetze unterschiedliche Dialekte und Abwandelungen dieser offiziellen Standards. Manche haben da auch Erweiterungen, dass man an untere Protokollschichten rankommt, also so etwas wie eine Art Paketznüffer in der Richtung machen kann. Allerdings die Art von Dokumentation über diese herstellerspezifischen proprätären Erweiterungen gibt es natürlich nur unter NDA.
Das heißt, wenn man mit diesem Funkteil kommuniziert über dieses Protokoll und man schickt der AT-Commandos-Roll, dann läuft ja auf der anderen Seite Software, an die man so nicht rankommt.
Das ist richtig.
Und das ist jetzt auch bei dem Neo1973-Phone so?
Das ist bei dem Telefon genauso. Das ist ein ganz klassisches Smartphone-Design. Das heißt, wir haben proprätäre Software auf dieser GSM-Seite, haben dann dieses Interface nach dem 07.x-Standard. Und auf der anderen Seite läuft dann die Freisoftware-Domäne, also mit Linux und X-Server und GTK und derartigen Dingen. Dass man da proprätäre Software auf der GSM-Seite hat, da wird man auf absehbare Zeit, schätze ich mal, nicht zum Rum kommen, weil einfach, man muss da ein bisschen weiter ansetzen, aber es gibt, glaube ich, keine andere Welt innerhalb der IT-Industrie, die so stark reguliert und beschränkt und unter der Kontrolle von ganz wenigen Firmen ist wie der Mobilfunkbereich. Und wenn man jetzt quasi freie Software auf der GSM-Seite haben will, dann müsste man anfangen, seinen eigenen Chipsatz zu entwickeln, weil es keinen Hersteller der Welt gibt, der einem jemals die Details offenbaren wird, die man bräuchte, um da eigene Software für den Teil zu schreiben.
Aber warum machen die das nicht? Weil sie es nicht dürfen? Wegen Patenten? Wegen lizenzrechtlichen Fragen? Weil sie keine Lust haben oder weil der Geheimdienst mit der Pistole hinter ihnen steht und sagt, wenn ihr das macht, dann weiß ja jeder, dass wir alle abhören? Also was…
Das ist eine Kombination aus unterschiedlichen Faktoren. Sicherlich spielen all diese Gründe eine Rolle. Ein Grund ist mit Sicherheit die regulatorischen Bestimmungen seitens FCC und anderen Standardisierungsbehörden, die darauf achten, dass die Bestimmungen, was Frequenzbandnutzung und so weiter betrifft, eingehalten werden. Das Problem hat man ja auch schon bei Wireless-Drivern im freien Softwareumfeld, bei GSM natürlich noch viel schlimmer. Zum anderen ist es aber einfach so, dass, wenn man mal Internet mit dem GSM-Netz vergleicht, dann ist GSM eben, also die Protokolle zwar bis auf die Krypto-Aspekte davon hundertprozentig offengelegt, aber alles in der Hand weniger Firmen und keinerlei öffentliche Schnittstellen oder sonst irgendwie öffentliche Interfaces oder irgendwas derartiges. Und das ganze Netz beruht im Wesentlichen da drauf auch, dass alle Leute, wie soll ich sagen, fair play sich verhalten. Das heißt, das Netz funktioniert, weil eben die Geräte alle mehr oder weniger unter der Kontrolle der Hersteller stehen und weil die Netzbetreiber mit den Geräteherstellern, sowohl was die Basisstation als auch die Mobilfunkgeräte betrifft, eben alle unter einer Decke stecken. Und wenn er jetzt auf einmal in ein Telefon käme, wo jemand irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Pakete mit, was weiß ich, irgendwelchen komischen Inhalten schicken würde, die Photokollege verletzen würden, dann würde es mich nicht wundern, wenn man da bei dem einen oder anderen Exploit oder Ähnlichem herauskommt, wie es im Internet auch aussieht, wenn man irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Pakete mit ungültigen Hatterflags oder sonst irgendwas durch die Gegend schickt.
Also ohne das jetzt vertiefen zu wollen, da ja im Prinzip die GSM-Seite vollständig offenspezifiziert ist, was hält einen eigentlich davon ab, jetzt auf Basis von, sagen wir mal, so einer Software-Suite wie Gnu Radio ein eigenes Telefondesign zu machen, wo vielleicht dann ein richtiger Prozessor die Arbeit macht. Leistungsfähig sind die Prozessoren auch im Embedded-Bereich mittlerweile genug, denke ich, um das zu leisten. Was ist da die Bremse? Könnte so ein Telefon nicht zugelassen werden?
Es wird mit Sicherheit nicht zugelassen werden, nach gängigen Zulassungsvorschriften im Moment. Was einen davon abhält, ist im Wesentlichen der Aufwand. Ich meine, wie viele Mobilfunk-Hersteller gibt es tatsächlich? Dann, wenn man das noch reduziert, auf wie viele Mobilfunk-Chipsats-Hersteller gibt es auf der Welt. Und dann wiederum haben nicht mal die alle ihren GSM-Stack-Server geschrieben, sondern lizenzieren den wieder. Und wenn man so mit Leuten aus der Mobilfunk-Branche spricht, ich bin ja niemand, der da aus der Ecke kommt, dann sagen die, naja, es gibt vielleicht 4 oder 5 GSM-Stack-Implementationen, das war's. Und die werden halt lizenziert von allen Firmen. Das heißt, sowas von Grund auf neu zu implementieren, geht sicherlich, weil man die ganzen Spezifikationen hat, aber es ist nicht unerheblich der ganze Signalverarbeitungsteil dran. Ich meine, einmal die ganzen Protokolle, wie man halt auch diese VIP hatte im Internetbereich oder halt noch Ethernet und was auch immer, aber dann eben diese ganze Funkgeschichte. GSM hat unglaublich strenge Auflagen, was Spektrumbreite und Zeit-Slot-Genauigkeit und solche Dinge hat. Und da steckt schon ziemlich viel Know-how drin. Das heißt, es sind schon ein paar Maniare, die da drinstecken. Und zum anderen dann eben, welche Firma würde diese Investition machen, wenn das Resultat danach dann eben nirgendwo zulassungsfähig wäre?
Ja gut, aber so ein Telefon, wenn es erst mal existieren würde, könnte man ja auch einschalten, ohne da auf eine Zulassung zu warten.
Ja, das wäre dann aber auch natürlich wieder nicht zulässig, weil es ist ja nicht zugelassen. Aber nein, natürlich wäre das auch mein Traum, so eine Art von Telefon zu haben. Und ich denke, irgendwann werden wir das auch sehen. Wahrscheinlich dann, wenn GSM gerade irgendwie ein halbes Jahr vor dem Abschalten steht, wird es so etwas mal geben. Sicher, ja. Aber im Moment haben wir ja noch nicht mal die Situation, dass wir wirklich im Handel befindliche Telefone hätten, die fertig entwickelt sind, wo überhaupt mal nur die PDA-Seite, sage ich mal, sogenannte Application-Processor.
Okay, ich denke, wir kommen da gleich auch noch mal auf den Bereich ein bisschen zurück, wenn es um Krypto geht, aber vielleicht sollten wir erst mal auf dieses Telefon, was jetzt unter Entwicklung ist, mal genau drauf schauen, um mal zu gucken, was da eigentlich genau drin ist. Da es ja jetzt vollständig spezifiziert ist, wenn man jetzt mal den GSM-Teil rausnimmt, ist das ja das, worauf sich im Prinzip die Entwickler derzeit konzentrieren, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Neo1973 heißt so, weil es ein neues Telefon ist und bezieht sich auf 1973, als ein Martin Cooper mal das erste Mobiltelefon erfunden und vorgestellt hat. Was steckt jetzt drin in der kleinen Büchse? Also klein ist es ja, also es ist wirklich so ein typisches kleines Phon. Der Bildschirm ist extrem hochauflösend. Was steckt unter der Haube?
Ja, also wir haben zum einen den GSM-Teil, das ist von Texas Instruments, ein sogenannter Calypsochipsatz. Der kann in der Variante, wie wir sie gegenwärtig vorliegen haben, die Hardware kann nur 2G, also GSM und GPRS, kein Edge, kein UMTS.
Also mit anderen Worten, normale Telefonierfunktion und so das Minimum an Datenpaketkommunikation, aber noch keiner der gesteigerten Hochgeschwindigkeiten, geschweige denn UMTS.
Und auf der PDA-Seite, wenn wir sie so bezeichnen wollen, ist es ein Samsung S3C2410, das ist ein sehr weit verbreiteter System-on-a-Chip, der einen ARM-920-Kern hat, also ARM-Architektur. Und wir haben da 128 MB, was für ein Telefon extrem viel ist, Arbeitsspeicher. Und in der aktuell vorliegenden Hardware 64 MB Flash. Wir kommen damit 64 MB aus, weil das konformiert ist. Es wird allerdings später vielleicht noch mal zu Roadmap kommen. In Kürze wird es eine Variante mit 1 GB geben. Dazu kommt noch ein Transflash-Slot. Transflash ist oder auch MicroSD ist der allerkleinste Formfaktor für Speichermedien. Und da gibt es Karten, bisher bis 2 GB und in Zukunft auch 4 GB Karten dafür.
Auch ein Bezahlbar?
Die sind auch bezahlbar.
Die 1 GB Karten kosten 17 Euro oder so. Also mit anderen Worten, gibt es schon einen Preis für das Neo1973?
Ja, der Preis, der jetzt von uns angesetzt wird für die sogenannte Phase 1. Phase 1 ist sozusagen öffentlicher Verkauf. Jeder kann sich eins bestellen. Allerdings, die Software noch für Entwickler, nicht für End-User, wird 350 US-Dollar sein. Das ist also ein außerordentlich vertretbarer Preis, so möchte ich meinen, für ein Telefon mit den Qualitäten. Das Display hat es schon angesprochen. Wir haben da tatsächlich ein Voll-VGA, also 640 x 480-Pixel-Display drin, mit 280 DPI. Ich habe noch nie ein Gerät in der Größe gesehen, das so ein hochauflösendes Display hat. Das ist doch noch hochauflösender als die Nokia 700er und auch die neuen Web-Folds, die auch schon eine sehr hohe Auflösung haben.
Und auch noch mal deutlich auflösender als das iPhone, das angekündigt ist, das liegt ja nur bei 160 DPI.
Ja, so, und das, wie gesagt, für 350 Dollar, denke ich schon, dass es ein sehr faires Angebot ist. Wie dann die andere Variante mit 1 GB eingebautem Flash und ein bisschen schnelleren Prozessoren, das steht im Moment noch nicht ganz fest. Aber es werden auf jeden Fall keine Rip-Off-Preise werden.
Schnittstellen hat das Ding auch?
Ja, nach außen hin einmal Bluetooth, also Bluetooth 2, für mobile Drahtdose-Kommunikation mit Laptop, Headset und sonstigen Gerätschaften. Es ist USB dran, leider nur USB 1. Das liegt im Wesentlichen daran, dass wir diesen Samsung-System auf dem Chip haben und der bietet eben keinen USB 2 intern an. Allerdings sind wir mit der Wahl unserer Hardware-Komponenten natürlich auch etwas eingeschränkt, weil wir ja versuchen, Hardware-Komponenten einzusetzen, die vollständig dokumentiert sind, öffentlich zugänglich, wo man kein NDA braucht, um irgendwie das User-Manuel zu bekommen. Und da gibt es dann nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viele Anbieter in dem Bereich.
Heißt das, dass man dann auch immer so ein bisschen dem aktuellen Hardware-Trend hinterher schleichen muss, um jetzt immer diese offenen Specks zu behalten? Weil USB 2.0 ist ja gerade, wenn man da jetzt 4 GB drin hat, will man ja da auch irgendwie mal die Daten drauf kriegen. So Musik und Filme vor allem.
Ja, also das ist in der Tat ein bisschen ungünstig. Das ist halt der Kompromiss, den wir jetzt gemacht haben. Dass man prinzipiell sagen kann, man ist auf ältere Hardware festgelegt, das kann man so nicht sagen. Das ist halt nur für uns auch als Newcomer sozusagen, sowohl was jetzt die Hardware-Architektur mit der Angabe möglichst lauter frei dokumentierte Komponenten einzusetzen, als auch auf der anderen Seite mit dieser freien Software, haben wir natürlich auch noch eine relativ ungünstige Marktposition gegenüber den Herstellern, um zu sagen, hey, naja, wir nehmen euren Chip nur, wenn ihr irgendwie euren Doku offen macht, dann ist es natürlich jetzt vielleicht beim zweiten oder dritten Telefon, wenn sich das mal erfolgreich verkauft hat, auch eine andere Ausgangsposition. Ich meine, FIC hat schon die entsprechenden Verbindungen. Ich meine, die kaufen ja nicht schlecht irgendwie Hardware-Komponenten ein bei Samsung oder ähnlichen Konzernen. Allerdings, wie gesagt, wir sind da sozusagen die Pioniere, was das betrifft, die Hardware-Steller davon zu überzeugen, entsprechend Dokumentationen daraus zu geben. Zum anderen die zeitlichen Einschränkungen. Also wenn man solche Diskussionen anfängt, dann dauert das halt mal schnell irgendwie ein paar Monate. Und wenn man dann irgendwie zehn solche Komponenten hat, dann braucht man irgendwie schon wieder beim nächsten Produkt anfangen, weil es veraltet ist.
Ja, mich wundert, dass jetzt auch dieses System-on-a-chip-Ding nicht alle ausreichend spezifiziert sind, weil wir ja gerade meinen, dass man so eine Systemintegration auf Dokumentation setzen sollte.
Ganz furchtbar. Sehr bedauerlich ist in dem Zusammenhang auch, muss ich an der Stelle loswerden, dass Intel, Intel hatte ja diese PXA 270 oder auch 250 vorher, X-Scale-Prozessoren hergestellt, die in unglaublich vielen Mobiltelefonen, Organisern, PDAs, was auch immer verbaut worden sind. Diese Business-Unit haben sie verkauft an Marvel. Seitdem ist da auch nichts mehr zu machen. Also Intel hat ja die Policy, eine wirklich Intel-weite Corporate Policy, die vorschreibt, dass sämtliche Hardware entweder offen zu dokumentieren ist oder GPL-lizenzierte Driver zur Verfügung zu stellen sind. Jede Abweichung davon muss explizit genehmigt werden. Und das war ganz traumhaft mit diesen X-Cale-Prozessoren. Jetzt haben sie das an Marvel verkauft und das macht Marvel. Bei Marvel bekommt man nicht mal mehr eine Produktliste, also eine Liste mit Chip-Bezeichnungen, die sie überhaupt herstellen, ohne dass man NDA unterschreibt. Also du kannst auf die Marvel-Seite gehen und da gibt es gerade noch einmal Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Bitte machen Sie sich einen Account und fachsen Sie uns dieses NDA, wenn Sie die Liste unserer Produkte sehen wollen.
Was steckt da dahinter?
Es ist einfach total bescheuert. Ich meine, selbst wenn man mal annehmen würde, dass irgendwo ganz hochgeheimes Intellectual Property stecken würde, dann aber doch bitte nicht in der Liste der Produkte, die man anbietet. Also es ist schon irgendwie alles sehr schräg. Aber gut, kommen wir zum Thema zurück.
Ja, das Thema ist das Telefon. Jetzt wissen wir etwa, was drin ist. Haben wir irgendwas rausgelassen? Also wir hatten jetzt den Bildschirm, Bluetooth, USB, die Schnittstellen. Man kann sich MicroSD reinstecken. Man hat ein bisschen RAM, ein bisschen Flash schon eingebaut. Und das könnte demnächst auch noch ein bisschen mehr werden. Das Ganze für 350 Dollar.
Was wir noch vergessen haben, ist der GPS-Teil. Es ist in dem Telefon auch ein GPS-Empfänger eingebaut, also für Global Positioning System zur Navigation.
Stimmt, und das Telefon hat auch gleich so einen externen Antennenanschluss dran, sodass man auch eine GPS-Antenne direkt ans Fenster kleben kann, damit das auch sinnvoll ist.
Genau. Der GPS-Empfänger ist...
Was ist da für ein Stein dahinter? Also der Chip?
Das ist ein relativ... Da sind wir technologisch ganz vorne. Das ist ein sogenannter Global Locate Hammerhead, der da drin steckt. Das ist das, was andere bekannte große, oder wie sie sagen, namhafte Hersteller von Navigationssystemen jetzt auch gerade einbauen in ihre neueste Produktgeneration. Das ist ein Assisted GPS. Das heißt, der kann durch Zuführen von externen Informationen, nämlich dieser sogenannten ephemeriden Daten, also die Satellitenlaufbahnen, noch schneller eine Locktime erreichen. Das heißt, er kann noch schneller eine Positionsbestimmung machen. Er kann es einfach schneller machen als eine herkömmliche GPS.
Wenn das Netz das unterstützt, gibt es denn schon GPS überhaupt? Wir hatten neulich mal eine Chaosradio-Sendung dazu. Da haben wir auch darüber gesprochen, dass es eingeführt werden soll. Ich kriege jetzt gerade nicht mehr zusammen, welcher Anbieter das vorhaben.
Es gibt mehrere Wege, um diese Daten zu dem GPS-Chip zu bekommen. Eine davon ist sozusagen auf GSM-Netzebene. Das ist meines Wissens nach ganz selten unterstützt und auch von Land zu Land und Anbieter zu Anbieter unabhängig. Das unterstützen wir erst gar nicht mal in unserem Telefon, zumindest bisher nicht. Das ist einfach Software, die man noch schreiben müsste. Das haben wir deswegen nicht implementiert, weil wir nicht wissen, dass das jemand wirklich benutzt von der Netzseite her. Was wir haben, ist die Möglichkeit, diese Daten über IP herunterzuladen. Das heißt, man macht das dann über GPS, wenn man sich den Datenverkehr finanziell erlauben kann, je nachdem, wie viel man dafür zahlt. Es sind nicht furchtbar viele Daten. Oder man kann natürlich auch, wenn man das Telefon zu Hause hat über Bluetooth oder über USB-Netzwerkprotokoll die Daten herunterladen, dass man das nicht über GPS machen muss, aber dann kann man sich da die nächsten paar Tage...
Ja, aber wo kriegt man denn die Daten her?
Zum einen betreibt der Hersteller Global Locket, der Hersteller des Chips-Servers, wo man das runterladen kann. Zum anderen gibt es die auch frei bei der NASA und bei irgendwelchen anderen...
Das heißt, das sind Daten, die nicht locationspezifisch sind. Ich muss dem nicht sagen, wo ich in etwa bin, sondern das ist im Prinzip die Gesamtinformation, wie die Satelliten gerade stehen.
Laufen, also es sind quasi die Abweichungen von den Soll-Umlaufbahnen der Satelliten, wie sie prognostiziert werden für die nächsten 48 Stunden.
Der Rest ist eh schon im Chip, sozusagen, als Intelligenz vorhanden. Und mit der zusätzlichen Information kann der Fix, also das Einstellen auf, wie sieht es jetzt wirklich genau aus, auf dem Himmel, schneller erfolgen.
Richtig, genau.
Aber funktioniert auch ohne das?
Funktioniert ohne das.
Das heißt, man hat im Prinzip ein Gerät, was Telefon ist und komplette GPS-Navi mit eingebaut hat.
Ja, wobei bei Navi hat man halt wieder das Problem, was...
Also Navi meine ich jetzt nicht Navisystem wie im Auto, sondern halt eine Navigationshilfe, weil man einfach schon mal die Position hat.
Ja, wir versuchen das also eher... Natürlich könnte jetzt auch... Also es gibt zwei, drei Projekte, die als Freisoftware, Navigations-Rooting-Systeme für Kartenmaterial und so implementieren. Das sind aber auch Projekte, die jetzt deutlich hinten nach sind, im Vergleich zu kommerziellen Anbietern. Dann hat man ja auch immer das Problem, wo bekommt man das Kartenmaterial her? Und dann gerade noch bei einem Telefon, das international verkauft wird, ja in jedem Land gibt es irgendwie andere Quellen für Kartenmaterial und andere Gesetzgebungen dazu.
Na gut, aber im Zweifelsfall, wenn man die Position hat, kann man sich ja auch einfach eine Web-Anwendung hochholen und sich das dann von Google Maps oder keine Ahnung...
Das ist richtig. Da gibt es die Möglichkeiten. Aber im anderen ist es so, dass für uns das GPS auch eher so eine Art Enabler für allgemein... Also, wie soll ich sagen, ortsbezogene Profile ist. Das heißt, wir haben so das Konzept von Dingen, die, na ja, wenn das Telefon weiß, dass ich gerade bei meinem Arbeitgeber bin und das ist ein privates Telefon zum Beispiel, dann kann das halt automatisch in den Silent Mode umschalten, wenn ich an der oder der Stelle bin, solche Dinge.
So Kino.
Nein, aber na ja, davor halt. Das ist also so ein Konzept und diese Information, an welchem Ort bin ich denn gerade, die kann halt zum einen kommen, von welchen Bluetooth-Geräten sind in der Umgebung. Also wenn mein Rechner zu Hause eine Bluetooth-Adresse hat, eine bestimmte, und das in der Wohnung ist, wo ich keinen Gebärsempfang habe, dann weiß das Telefon trotzdem, ich bin zu Hause, weil zu Hause ist eben dieses Bluetooth irgendwie in der Nähe. Und so über derartige Dinge, auch im Übrigen hat man immer noch die Zell-IDs, also vom GSM-Netz her, also an welcher Basisstation bin ich gerade angemeldet zum Beispiel. Also über das System funktionieren ja auch diese Homezones von den diversen Mobilfunkanbietern. Und also man hat schon einiges an unterschiedlichen Informationsquellen, wo bin ich denn gerade, mit unterschiedlicher Genauigkeit natürlich, aber das ist quasi unser primäres Einsatzgebiet für dieses GPS, um zu sagen, wir wollen dem Anwender die Möglichkeit geben, Funktionen des Telefons und Profile und Äthertik auch an Orte koppeln und nicht nur an Zeit oder so.
Jetzt wendet sich das Telefon ja primär auch erstmal an einen Entwickler, weil da ist noch eine ganze Menge Arbeit zu tun. Haben wir denn die Hardware jetzt komplett durch?
Die Hardware haben wir jetzt komplett durch, das ist richtig.
Was wir noch nicht erwähnt haben, ist, auf dem Display ist natürlich auch noch ein Touchscreen mit drauf. Das heißt, man kann entweder mit so einem kleinen Stylus oder auch direkt mit dem Finger auf die Display rumtappern.
Das ist richtig.
Und damit haben wir auch den Hardware-Teil. Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie kriegt man das alles zum Laufen? Was befindet sich jetzt eigentlich auf diesem Telefon? Und wo kommt das her? Was macht das OpenMoko-Projekt?
Ja, also zualler nächst können wir mal ganz unten anfangen. Wenn ich irgendeinen Computer booten will, dann habe ich da immer einen Bootloader. Der Bootloader, den wir verwenden, ist U-Boot. Der ist sehr bekannt im freien Softwarebereich. Er ist also ein Bootloader, der für sehr viele unterschiedliche Architekturen und System-on-a-Chips läuft. Wir haben da sehr viel noch dazu geschrieben, um den erstens für ein Gerät fit zu machen, was keine Tastatur oder Ähnliches hat, wo man mit dem Bootloader interagieren könnte. Zum anderen ist natürlich bei so einem Telefon doch noch einiges an Details anders als bei einem normalen Embedded-Gerät. Man denkt nur an das ganze Power-Management und ähnliche Dinge. Der Bootloader ist U-Board, GPL-sensierte Software, die von uns entsprechend weiter rangefasst wird. Dann als Kern haben wir eben Linux, gegenwärtig in der Version 2.6.20.1. Das war bis heute Vormittag die letzte stabile Version. Jetzt gibt es die 2.6.20.2. Das werde ich heute Abend oder morgen dann merken.
Also in anderen Worten ein topaktuelles Linux. Da ist nicht irgendeine alte Version drauf, sondern man fährt the latest and greatest.
Unsere Philosophie ist von der Software-Seite her die ganzen Dinge, die üblicherweise Hersteller, wenn sie mit freier Software arbeiten, falsch zu machen, richtig zu machen. Zumindest die Leute, die das Projekt initiiert haben, sind Leute, die aus der freien Software-Community kommen. Die wissen, wie das alles läuft, wie das funktioniert. Was erwarten die Hacker von funktionierendem Software-Design? Und wir kommen nicht von der Firmen-Seite her. Deswegen ist es für mich eine der Hauptarbeiten, nicht nur die Entwicklung, sondern auch diese ganze Corporate-Welt klarzumachen, wie freie Software-Entwicklung aussieht. Dass man nicht irgendwelchen Code hier nimmt, den forkt und den so irgendwie shippt, sondern dass man saubere Patches macht, Feature für Feature, dass man die oben aufsetzt, dass man die wieder zurückmercht in die eigentlichen ursprünglichen Software-Projekte und so weiter.
Um das auch am Leben zu erhalten, dass eben das nicht einfach nur so einmal läuft und danach kümmert sich keiner mehr drum, sondern dass man auch die Community für sich gewinnt und sagt, ok, hier gibt es eine populäre neue Plattform, ist ein Telefon, brauchen wir sowieso, wir haben nicht nur Desktop, Computer und Laptops, sondern wir müssen auch das aktiv unterstützen und wenn man sich dann auch beteiligend bei den anderen Projekten mit einbringt, dann kann man auch erwarten, dass man etwas zurückbekommt.
Das ist richtig, zum anderen dient das aber auch uns. Also wir wollen hier wirklich, wie soll ich sagen, Standard ist übertrieben, aber naja gut, zumindest was jetzt diese wirklich echte, freie Software-Architektur für Smartphones betrifft, wollen wir schon hier irgendwie mal ein gutes Beispiel hinstellen und das ist schon so ausgelegt, dass das eben für viele Arten von Geräten und über längere Zeit auch funktionieren kann und deswegen müssen wir natürlich auch schauen, dass wir irgendwie, ich betrachte das ja immer als nachhaltige Softwareentwicklung betreiben, das heißt, der ganze Teil von dem, was wir entwickeln, der in die Upstream-Projekte, also jetzt beispielsweise in den Linux-Körnern oder diesen Bootloader hinein integriert wird, den müssen wir schon nicht mehr maintainen, also das ist für uns dann kein Aufwand mehr, sondern das ist in den Projekten drin. Ja und das ist eine Denke, die für diese embedded Software-Entwickler in Fernost irgendwie völlig neu ist, dass man keine Wegwerfprodukte entwickelt, sondern dass man irgendwie Dinge entwickelt, die also von über viele Jahre hinweg funktionieren sollen und auch immer mitwachsen mit der Technologie.
Mit anderen Worten, da ist auch eine ganze Menge Energie nötig gewesen, diese neue Denke dann auch bei den Projektpartnern zu installieren.
Das ist in der Tat schon ein extremer, wie soll ich sagen, ein extremer Umschwung dort, ja. Also das klappt mal mehr, mal weniger, das muss ich ganz offen zugestehen. Das hätte ich mir nicht so schwierig vorgestellt. Aber man muss natürlich auch sehen, die personelle Situation. Wir haben jetzt im Moment aus der Community, wenn man mal Sean dazuzählt, der ist jetzt zwar kein richtiger Entwickler, aber auch jemand, der so aus der Philosophie heraus und so weiter kommt, dann bin ich zuständig, also offizielle Vertitelung, was war es doch gleich, System Level, Architekt, nein, wie war das noch, Senior Software, Architekt, System Level, genau. Das heißt, ich bin also für die Systemebene zuständig, das heißt eben Bootloader, Kranel, diese GSM-Kommunikation, Infrastruktur, Netzwerkunterstützung, Bluetooth, diese ganzen Sachen. Die User-Interface-Geschichten macht Michael Lauer, der ist in Frankfurt auch ein Deutscher hier. Also er ist für die Widgets und die User-Interface-Klassen und diese Dinge zuständig, die es eben gibt, auf der Ebene.
Hat dieser Sean auch einen Nachnamen?
Moss-Puls mit TZ, deswegen sage ich immer nur Sean, weil M-U-S-P-U-L-T-Z immer etwas kompliziert ist.
Was heißt drei Leute, die jetzt im Wesentlichen...
Na, es gibt noch Werner Almesberger, der auch ein bekannter Linux-Entwickler ist, der mir jetzt noch zu Hilfe kommt. Wir sind weiter dabei, gerade noch ein paar Leute zu integrieren. Aber jetzt so traditionell sind es wirklich einfach drei Mann gewesen. Das sind als erste halbe Jahr lang drei Leute. Und gegenüber einem Konzern, was weiß ich, wie viele 1000 Mitarbeiter, dann ist das natürlich schon eine Geduldsprobe, sich immer wieder zu wiederholen und zu sagen, wir können aber jetzt nicht diese Komponente nehmen, weil wir haben da andere Prioritäten. Wir nehmen halt nicht den billigsten Chip, sondern wir nehmen den, wo die Doku am offensten ist. Das ist schon für eingespielte Leute in der Branche ein Lernprozess. Da geht natürlich schon ziemlich viel Zeit erstmal verloren.
Aber trotzdem das Projekt als solches, also die Community, die du jetzt mit Personen konkret benannt hast, sind schon erfahrene Leute, die wissen, was sie tun.
Das ist jetzt nur die Core-Gruppe sozusagen. Darum gibt es zum einen die Firma Open Hand in England, die auch sehr viel für diese Nokia 77 und diese Web-Tablets gemacht hat. Das sind also Spezialisten, was GTK-Anwendungen, also dieses GUI Toolkit aus der Gnomecke, was solche Anwendungen auf mobilen Endgeräten betrifft. Dann die Sound-Driver und Audio-Architektur kommt von Wolfson Microelectronics, das ist der Hersteller vom Soundchip. Die arbeiten aber selber auch ganz aktiv und sehr stark an exzellenten gefälligensierten Drivern für ihre Bausteine. Dann gibt es eine Firma, die heißt Funambol, die machen SyncML, also Synchronisierungsgeschichten. Die ist mit im Boot für die Synchronisierung von unseren PIM-Anwendungen mit der Desktop-Seite usw. Da gibt es eine ganze Menge von Partnern und auch die Entwickler-Gemeinde. Seit dem 11. Februar haben wir alles, also unser Wiki, den Quellcode-Baum, der Bugzilla und all diese Tools sind offen. Jeder kann einsehen, jeder kann sich auf die Mailing-Listen subscribieren und teilnehmen an dem ganzen Projekt.
Wie groß ist das Interesse an dem Projekt von außen?
Außerordentlich groß, man könnte fast sagen zu groß, weil da natürlich auch sehr viel Aufwand sozusagen mit der externen Kommunikation drauf geht. Ich habe jetzt keine aktuellen Zahlen, aber wir hatten also, wir haben eine Community-Mailing-Liste, das ist unsere älteste öffentliche Mailing-Liste, wo wir also seit Ende letzten Jahres, schon bevor wir Quellcode und irgendwie sonstige Dinge offen gelegt haben, versucht haben, ein bisschen ein Forum zu bieten für Leute, die sich da interessieren dafür. Und da waren damals schon, bevor wir überhaupt unsere Sachen offen gelegt hatten, irgendwie knapp 3000 Leute drauf. Also es ist wirklich...
Alle wollen ein Telefon.
Ja, vielen Leuten scheint es unter dem Nagel zu brennen, oder wie auch immer man das ausdrücken mag, jetzt endlich mal ein Telefon zu haben, wo man irgendwie seine eigene Software drauflaufen lassen kann.
Gut, Stichwort eigene Software drauflaufen lassen. Jetzt haben wir ja schon gesagt, da gibt es halt so eine Systemarchitektur, die basiert auf Linux. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch eine grafische Anwendung, die basiert auf der G-Welt.
Genau.
Es gibt die G-Welt, es gibt die K-Welt, hier kommt die G-Welt. G-Welt war schon immer sehr stark eigentlich im mobilen Bereich. Nokia hat ja auch dieses 770. Es war kein Telefon, aber zumindest wie ein Telefon aussehen, das mobiles Gerät. Auch da war ja schon genommen, also GTK-basierte Oberfläche. Ist das ähnlich, muss man sich das ähnlich vorstellen, oder kommt was ganz anderes dabei raus?
Von der darunter liegenden Architektur ist es in der Tat ähnlich. Das heißt, wir nehmen so diese G-Welt, also G-Lib, GTK, G-DK, Pango, Artika, was weiß ich, G-Conf, D-Bass, was auch immer, um jetzt noch ein paar irgendwie abkürzungenen Axonime in das Mikrofon zu kotzen.
Genau, um den Podcast schön komplex zu machen.
Ja, das heißt, das ist schon in der Tat richtig. Wir haben aber da oben drauf, und zwar in der Tat tatsächlich völlig sauber oben drauf. Wir patchen keines dieser Pakete, also wir haben kein verändertes GTK und so weiter, das sind alles ganz normal, die Vanilla-Sourcen, wie man so schön sagt, im Kauder Welch. Und oben drauf legen wir unsere eigenen Widgets und Klassen und so weiter. Da gibt es einmal die sogenannte libmoko UI, also für User Interface, die dann die Widgets, die wir eben in unseren sogenannten native OpenMoko-Anwendungen verwenden. Also da gibt es dann sowas wie Finger-Buttons, das sind Knöpfe, die eben so groß sind, dass man sie mit dem Finger bedienen kann. Da gibt es ein Finger-Wheel, das ist zum Scrollen mit dem Finger auf dem Display. Dann gibt es halt irgendwelche Entry-Boxen und Dropdown-Menüs und so weiter, wie man das halt hat bei grafischen Oberflächen. Aber wir haben da eben unsere eigenen Klassen aufsetzend auf GTK. Das heißt, wir können jede beliebige GTK-Anwendung, die man unter Linux oder anderen Unix-artigen Betriebssystemen übersetzen kann, können wir eben auch auf dem Telefon laufen lassen. Nicht zuletzt wegen der hohen Auflösung. Also alles, was auf einem 640 x 480 Low-Resolution-Desktop-WC laufen würde, kann auch auf dem Telefon laufen. Allerdings, die Anwendungen, die wir schreiben, die benutzen eben nicht das GTK direkt, sondern da liegen dann diese OpenMoko-Komponenten, also die Klassen, das sogenannte OpenMoko-Framework, genau, der Name ist es, dazwischen, damit unsere Anwendungen alle ein einheitliches Look and Feel haben und einheitlich integriert sind und so weiter.
Was ja sicherlich sehr wichtig ist, weil ich denke, von einem Telefon erwarten die meisten Leute nicht unbedingt, dass es jetzt daherkommt, wie der typische Linux-Desktop eines Entwicklers. Die Linux-Welt hat sich ja schon immer ein bisschen schwergetan mit einfach zu benutzenden Benutzerschnittstellen. Da tut sich natürlich eine ganze Menge und in letzter Zeit gibt es auch riesige Fortschritte, nicht nur in der G-Welt, sondern auch in der K-Welt. Da habe ich ja auch neulich mal einen Podcast so gemacht und war auch vor kurzem auf der Forstin in Brüssel. Also es gibt da sehr viel Bewegung. Was ist denn so der Ansatz an der Stelle? Inwieweit wird denn da über das User-Interface neu nachgedacht, um jetzt auch wirklich ein Telefon zu produzieren, was mithalten kann, was bisher derzeit auf dem Markt ist? Ist furchtbar, schlimm und grausam. Ich leide selbst erheblich unter meinem Nokia-Telefon und auch mit allen anderen habe ich eigentlich wenig Freude. Was habt ihr denn da für einen Ansatz?
Ja, da bin ich jetzt so ein bisschen der Inkompetente.
Ja, ich weiß, aber du weißt ja, dass Leute dran arbeiten.
Ich sage das nur vorab, man möge mir verzeihen, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Dinge nicht im richtigen Lichte beschreiben. Also ich bin da schon auch so bei der Konzeptionierung mit beteiligt, dieses User-Interface, ist da natürlich eher so die funktionale Seite, das heißt, welche Funktionen brauchen wir, wie stellen wir die vielleicht da und so. Was diese ganze, also dann die eigentliche Führung durch das Interface und diese ganzen Dinge betrifft, da bin ich jetzt wirklich absolut gar nicht integriert. Es ist schon so, dass wir uns einfach als, wie soll ich mal sagen, Power-User oder Leute, die sehr stark mit technischen Geräten interagieren, hingesetzt haben und gesagt haben, na ja, was möchten wir denn eigentlich von so einem Telefon? Was soll das können? Welche Funktion braucht irgendwie dieser Dialer, also Dialer ist sozusagen die Telefonanwendung davon. Und was will man da haben, was will man nicht? Und wir haben da schon eben sehr an uns selber gedacht, also einen sehr technischen Anwenderkreis, der gerne tolle Features hat. Auf der anderen Seite ist Sean aber eben jemand, der aus der klassischen Design-Ecke kommt, der hat irgendwelche Webdesign-Awards bekommen in den USA mal früher und was auch immer. Also jemand, der wirklich ein Auge hat für sämtliche Arten von sowohl jetzt optisches Design, aber auch eben User-Interface-Design-Geschichten. Und jetzt von den Features zum Beispiel, also was ich schon immer mal haben wollte, ist eine anständige Communication-Historie in einem Telefon. Das heißt so was wie an den Kontakt gebunden. Wann habe ich zum letzten Mal mit ihm telefoniert? Wann habe ich ihn angerufen? Wann hat er mir angerufen? So eine Art Backlog. Das Ganze dann kombiniert mit einem Backlog der SMS oder dann am besten noch der E-Mails, die man ihm geschickt hat und solche Dinge. Also einfach wirklich funktional Dinge zu bieten, die wir uns als irgendwie aus dem Internet kommenden Techies, sage ich mal, gedacht haben, dass man die eigentlich endlich mal bräuchte.
Wird es denn auch ein E-Mail-Client geben? Also ein Web-Browser ist wahrscheinlich auf jeden Fall drauf.
Wichtig.
Aber es soll auch ein E-Mail-Client. Was nimmt man da? Also wird da auch was Neues gebaut?
Na, da gibt es die sogenannte Dates- und Contacts-Anwendung. Also es gibt quasi so eine PIM, oder eine in Entwicklung befindliche PIM-Suite, wie man das sagt, also diese passende Information. Manager, also Kalender, dann auch mit Synchronisierung und so weiter und Kontaktverwaltung.
Das wird alles neu entwickelt, oder da wird was genommen, was es schon gibt?
Da gab es, die Firma OpenTent hat da eben schon angefangen gehabt, was zu entwickeln in dem Bereich. Die nehmen also so diese Konzepte aus dem Gnome-Desktop-Bereich, also dieser sogenannte Enlightenment-Database-Server, IDS zum Beispiel als Backend mit dem entsprechenden APs, den IDS-APs dann über Debuss zu den Frontend-Anwendungen. Und die hatten da eben angefangen, schon Dinge zu machen, die sehr vielversprechend aussehen und da gibt es jetzt eben entsprechend das Abkommen, dass die das weiterentwickeln und speziell für OpenMoko eben mit unserem User-Interface verheiratet werden. Ja, ja.
Das ist für mich die wichtigste Anwendung.
Für mich natürlich auch. Das ist ja eben das Schöne, dass da so Leute dran arbeiten, die irgendwie ein ähnliches Kommunikationsgebaren an den Tat legen. Was wir eigentlich wollen, ich kann jetzt nicht versprechen, bis wann wir das geschafft haben, aber was sozusagen auf unserer Roadmap und in der Spezifikation entsteht, ist, dass das alles zu vereinheitlichen ist. Das heißt, dass SMS und XMPP gleichbehandelt da stehen und dass ich halt einfach irgendwo auswähle, will ich jetzt das als SMS senden oder eben als XMPP-Message, in Abhängigkeit davon, ob ich natürlich die entsprechenden Assistenten im Kontakt zu entstehen habe. Aber dass das auch in der History eben völlig, es ist egal, über welches Kommunikationsmedium habe ich das geschickt, das ist einfach so vereinheitliche Darstellung von Kommunikationsthreads und E-Mail dann eben auch dort mit hinein integriert.
Aber es gibt jetzt halt noch keinen Java-Client, der auf dem Telefon läuft?
Na, keinen, der jetzt in diese OpenMoko-Architektur eingebettet wird.
Natürlich gibt es welche, die laufen, weil es ist halt Linux und es ist GTK, ist klar. Also es ist auf jeden Fall absehbar, dass das kommen wird und alle denken da drüber nach.
Das ist richtig. Ansonsten möchte ich noch zu deiner ursprünglichen Sache, na ja, mir gefällt das alles nicht, was bisherige Telefone machen und so. Das heißt, wenn wir dann jetzt erstmal ein User-Interface haben, auch wenn es jetzt, und wenn es dann irgendwie eine, sagen wir mal, eine alleine wird es wahrscheinlich nicht schaffen, aber wenn es dann zwei, drei Leute gibt, die sagen, uns stinkt das jetzt so, das passt uns überhaupt nicht, wir wollen das anders haben, dann kann man das mit unserem Telefon ja auch tatsächlich anders machen. Das ist halt der große Unterschied. Und man muss dann nicht anfangen, alles von vorn zu schreiben, sondern man hat ja eben schon den ganzen Quellkod da für die Funktionalität und kann sich dann vielleicht nur noch über das Interface Gedanken machen, um das zu verbessern.
Da muss ich jetzt aber nochmal ganz frech als Podcaster auch reinfragen, wird denn das Ding auch ein ordentliches Mikrofon haben irgendwie? Oder kann ich über USB eins anschließen oder...
Ein ordentliches Mikrofon? Na, da ist wahrscheinlich kein ordentliches drin. Das ist halt eins, was zum Telefonieren tut.
Aber einen Audio-Eingang in dem Sinne gibt es erstmal noch nicht?
Einen Audio-Eingang gibt es nicht. Ich habe mir mal einen dran gelötet, um was zu nennen. Nein, einen Line-In gibt es nicht. Das haben wir auf der Roadmap für zukünftige Hardware. Das ist auf der Wishlist eigentlich, aber doch auf der Roadmap schon. Was geht oder was wir unterstützen werden ist A2DP, also dieses Bluetooth-Audio-Protokoll.
Stereo-Headphones über Bluetooth, sozusagen.
Genau, aber das geht ja zumindest vom Protokoll nicht nur für Headphones, sondern auch für Musik in das Gerät hinein, Ideen. Was für Hardware es gibt, die sowas unterstützt, das kann ich jetzt natürlich nicht sagen. Die andere Variante ist natürlich, das über USB zu tun, in welcher Art auch immer. Unsere Standard-Konfiguration auf dem USB ist auch wieder ganz untypisch für Telefone, weil wir dann nämlich ein Netzwerk-Interface auf dem USB haben und nicht irgendwie eine verkorkste, emulierte Serie, Schnittstelle oder irgend sowas. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich meinen PC, und wohlgemerkt nicht nur den Linux-PC, sondern auch den Windows- oder MacOS-PC mit dem Telefon verbinde, dann erscheint das Telefon sozusagen wie ein Netzwerk-Interface. Und ich spreche da TCP-IFE mit dem Telefon, ich kann SSH drauf machen, ich kann mir die Anwendungen über X11 vom Telefon rüberholen auf meinen X-sprechenden PC oder was auch immer.
Das heißt, ich schließe das Telefon einfach über USB an meinen Laptop an und dann erscheint das als Netzwerk-Schnittstelle.
Genau.
Kann ich darüber, was weiß ich, PPP machen und habe Internet oder wie läuft das?
Nein, nicht mal PPP, sondern wenn du jetzt über das Telefon selber ins Netz gehen wolltest, dann sieht es aus wie ein Ethernet-Device sozusagen.
Und dann macht das Telefon für mich dann auch DHCP und so weiter, dann kriege ich die IP-Adressen davon. Ah, alles klar, also im Prinzip wie so ein DSL-Router, den man direkt an seinen Rechner anschließt.
Genau, es ist quasi wie ein Router, nur dass er nach oben in eben GPS spricht.
Ah, ja, da sprichst du aber schon einen ganz interessanten Bereich an, weil über Linux-Integrationen haben wir natürlich jetzt, also das ist ja sozusagen der totale No-Brainer, wenn das Telefon selber von der Linux-Community entwickelt wird und unter Linux läuft, dann wird natürlich die Integration unter Linux gut laufen. Gibt es dann auch schon Projekte, die jetzt auch ganz gezielt versuchen, dieses Telefon von vorne ran zu so einem First Class Citizen mit den populären Desktop-Plattformen zu machen?
Ist mir jetzt nicht bekannt, das wäre wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen zu früh im Moment. Weil wir ja, also es ist einfach noch sehr viel Flux überall drin im Projekt. Ich denke, das ist eher was, was man dann, wenn die eigentliche Kommunikation und Integration mit der Linux-Seite auf dem Desktop sauber läuft, dann kann man sozusagen diese Dinge übertragen auf die Windows und Mac OS Welt. Wir haben das natürlich im Hinterkopf mit der Entwicklung oder während der Entwicklung. Was wir eben wissen oder was wir, also ist, dass diese Netzwerk-Funktionalität gegeben ist, auch unter den populären Betriebssystemen. Ansonsten darüber hinausgehend, wie es jetzt zum Beispiel mit der ganzen Synchromisierung und Integration und derartigen Dingen ist, kann ich im Moment nicht beantworten, aber es ist definitiv in der Spezifikation des Produkts enthalten, dass das auch funktioniert unter anderem Betriebssystem.
Aber das ist ja im Prinzip dann auch die schöne Sache. Das System ist komplett offen für Entwickler und schafft ja an der Stelle dann auch Möglichkeiten für neue Entwickler dazuzukommen. Was ist so deine Botschaft an potenziell eine Plattform interessierter Entwickler, was sie jetzt am besten tun sollten?
Ja, naja, wir sind leider eben sehr stark im Verzug. Das hatte ich jetzt in der Stelle auch noch nicht gesagt. Ursprünglich hätten wir schon Ende November letzten Jahres, glaube ich, die ersten Telefone auch an Entwickler rausgeben wollen. Das hat sich dann verschoben auf... Ursprünglich haben wir gesagt Mitte Februar, dann gab es noch mal ein Hardware-Problem. Also wir hatten unglaublich viele Schwierigkeiten mit Hardware-Bugs. Und haben jetzt dann, ich glaube, vor, naja, einer Woche oder so knapp, ja doch letzten Freitag, glaube ich, oder Samstag, haben wir die ersten Telefone dann verschickt. Also wir haben gesagt, 50 Entwickler kriegen von uns kostenlosen Telefon. Da haben wir uns mal überlegt, welche Leute aus der freien Software-Community man eben da...
Also letzte Woche Anfang März, für die Leute, die diesen Podcast irgendwann hören. Anfang März 2007.
Ja, gingen sie raus. Es wird, also die Hardware ist da, alles bis zum X hoch sozusagen, also die ganze Systemebene und auch User-Interface und so geht. Aber unsere ganzen eigenen Anwendungen, also das, wovon ich jetzt gesprochen habe, diese ganze Integration und was auch immer, da steht noch sehr viel Arbeit bevor. Das ist das, worauf wir uns jetzt verstärkt stürzen werden, nachdem die Hardware-Probleme alle gelöst sind und die System-Level-Probleme sozusagen auch im Software-Bereich. Man kann also jetzt noch nicht irgendwie einfach, was weiß ich, sowas wie eine vollständige A4-Referenz für die OpenMoko-Klassenbibliotheken oder sowas gibt es noch nicht, weil da noch sehr viele Änderungen drin sind. Das ist auch gerade das Schöne, dass wir auch intern so einen evolutionären, freien Software-Entwicklungsprozess haben. Das heißt, da gibt es jetzt niemanden, der eine Bibliothek schreibt mit einer API-Spezifikation. Dann gibt es den Typen daneben, der schreibt eine Anwendung. Und wenn ihm die API nicht passt, dann muss er sich da irgendwie übel drum rumhacken, sondern wenn der Anwendungsentwickler halt noch irgendwas braucht in der darunterliegenden Klassenbibliothek, dann hackt er das halt in die noch mit rein. Und das ganze Interface entwickelt sich dann eben. Es gibt auch nichts, was ich jetzt in irgendeiner Art und Weise als eine stabile Release oder überhaupt als eine Release bezeichnen würde. Wir haben, offiziell betiteln wir die gegenwärtige Firmware oder halt die Software-Images für die Geräte auch als Snapshots. Das heißt, das sind eigentlich einfach so Aktuell-Schnapschüsse des Entwicklungsstadiums. Entwickler, die interessiert sind, was zu machen mit dem Telefon oder überhaupt mit der Software-Architektur, mit dem OpenMoko, würde ich im Moment empfehlen, einfach mal sich anschauen, was bei uns im Subversion-Server liegt, sich ein bisschen die Bibliotheken anschauen. Vor allem kann man sich im Moment schon beschäftigen mit dem Open-Embedded-System. Was wir machen, ist ja letztendlich eine GNU slash Linux-Distribution, um das in RMS-kompatiblen Terminologie auszudrücken. Diese Distribution muss ja von irgendwas gebaut werden. Bei Red Hat gibt es APMs, bei Debian gibt es Dpkg als Paketformat und als Paketverwaltungssystem. Und wir haben das sogenannte IPK-System, das ist was auch im Open-Zaurus und im Open-WRT-Projekt und so verwendet wird als Paketformat im Embedded-Vereich. Und gebaut wird diese ganze Distribution, muss ja alles cross-compiled werden und so. Mit einem System, das heißt Open Embedded. Und Open Embedded ist sozusagen eine Meta-Distribution, also ein Distribution Building Framework. Und man kann mittels Open Embedded sich die Open-Moko-Distribution bauen lassen, komplett aus dem Quellcode, ohne dass man überhaupt irgendwas sozusagen von vornherein darlegen hat. Da wird erstmal der Cross-Compiler gebaut und die, was weiß ich, diese ganze Toolchain und so weiter. Das heißt, wenn man dann später mal Softwarepakete entwickeln will und auch ausführen will auf dem Telefon oder auf irgendeinem Telefon, was unterstützt wird, dann muss man natürlich mit diesem Open Embedded umgehen können, um überhaupt Pakete bauen zu können für die Zielplattform. Das heißt, jeder, der da einsteigen will...
Das kann sich jetzt schon mal ein bisschen Training angedeihen lassen, damit er überhaupt diesen Entwicklungsprozess mitverfolgen kann. Und gibt es bestimmte Arten von Programmierern oder Sachen, nach denen ihr gerade besonders fahndet oder wo ihr Verstärkungen gut gebrauchen könntet?
Was wir im Moment dringend brauchen, sind Leute, die wirklich viel Erfahrung haben im GTK-Anwendungsentwicklungsbereich. Das heißt, so mit Systemlevel-Leuten wie mir, da sind wir gut versorgt und brauchen auch nicht mehr so viele. Auch was jetzt Packaging und solche Dinge betrifft, da sind wir auch gut ausgerüstet mit Know-how.
Aber User-Interface.
Ja, muss nicht unbedingt mal User-Interface sein. Es sind ja doch dann sehr komplexe Anwendungen. Wenn man sich diesen Dialer anschaut mit dieser ganzen Kommunikationshistorie und Autocompletion von Telefonnummern und was das alles an Featuren drin hängen, auch diese ganzen Dinge wie, was weiß ich, dass dann mal noch reagiert werden muss auf ganz komische Dinge im Telefoniebereich. Also wenn da jetzt irgendwie die Verbindung abbricht oder was auch immer, da gibt es ja lauter so Stages, die mal irgendwie passieren können und die man normalerweise gar nicht denkt, die man gar nicht mitbekommt. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall sehr viel Komplexität in diesen Anwendungen vorhanden. Wir suchen Leute, die sich eben mit der GTK-Welt auskennen, sehr gut. Also GTK heißt jetzt dann eben die Object-Pango und was auch immer alles in dem Bereich.
Das, was man halt auch so unter Gnome normalerweise eben programmiert.
Genau, auch D-Bus, also das Desktop-Bus-System, diese Messaging-Architektur, die verwenden wir auch auf dem Telefon. Und zwar eben wirklich Leute, die Anwendungen von Grund auf entwickelt haben schon mal. Komplex, oder? Jetzt nicht irgendwie mal hier und da ein Patch vielleicht irgendwo geschrieben oder mal ein Code gelesen, sondern Leute, die wirklich echt Erfahrung haben in der Anwendungsentwicklung, also from scratch in dem Bereich. Da könnten wir ein paar Leute gebrochen und wir können anbieten Bezahlungen für Entwicklungen von GPL-lizenzierter Software in einem doch sehr interessanten Bereich. Ich denke, da ist es doch schon sehr attraktiv mitzuarbeiten.
Und man hat auch die Möglichkeit, einem doch recht groundbreaking Projekt teilzunehmen, wo dann später Millionen Leute mit der Software dann auch arbeiten auf diesen portablen Geräten. Weil es gibt definitiv, denke ich, einen großen Bedarf an einem freien Telefon. Nicht nur, damit man mal irgendwie seinen Lidungs drauf hat, sondern darauf wollte ich jetzt nochmal so kommen. Telefone sind natürlich auch ein, wie soll ich sagen, ein Ort, wo doch extrem Kommunikation betrieben wird. Man telefoniert, man verschickt E-Mail, man chattet, man macht SMS. Und das ist natürlich dann auch alles so ein bisschen sicherheits- und privatsphärenrelevant. Wo siehst du denn da so die Vorteile des Telefons gegenüber anderen Telefonen, die man so jetzt im Laden kaufen kann? Und was ist da auch eure Security-Strategie?
Ja, also zunächst ist es so, dass wir natürlich einmal diesen ganzen populären GSM-Bereich haben, der uns natürlich auch aus Sicherheitsaspekten heraus sehr suspekt vorkommt. Ich bin ja auch jemand, der eher so aus der IT-Security kommt und da ist mir das natürlich auch ein Daumen im Auge. So, jetzt gibt es dann natürlich die Leute, ob man sie jetzt als Verschwörungstheoretiker bezeichnen will oder nicht. Die sagen, na ja, aber da haben doch die ganzen Geheimdienste dieses Feature, das Mikrofon von einem Telefon anzuschalten und Leute abzuhören. Und genau das kann man mit unserem Telefon garantiert umgehen, weil nämlich alles, was irgendwie in dieses GSM-Modul rein oder raus geht, dass sie wieder Audio-Signale erst mal über die von Linux konsolierte Seite geht. Das heißt, wenn ich im Audio-Mixer von der Linux-Seite her irgendwie das Mikrofon auf Mute setze oder halt überhaupt zum Beispiel die Phantomspannung für das Mikrofon ausschalte, dann weiß ich, dass es aus. Und da kann der GSM-Teil schreien und tun und quietschen, aber er kann dieses Mikrofon nicht einschalten. Das heißt, das ist sozusagen schon mal von der Hardware-Architektur her ausgeschlossen, dass sowas gehen würde, selbst wenn solche Backdoors in dem GSM-Stack drin wären. Auch den GSM-Teil kann ich komplett ausschalten, dass das auch gewährleistet, weil man eben einfach die Spannung ausschalten kann von der Linux-Seite her und dann ist er halt weg.
Das heißt, man kann sicherstellen, dieses Telefon ist auf gar keinen Fall irgendwie eingebucht. Es kann nicht getreckt werden vom GSM-Netz.
Genau, das kann man sicherstellen. Und eben, wie gesagt, diese Abhörfunktion kann man auch sicherstellen, dass die nicht gegeben ist.
Früher war das ja immer so ein bisschen der Running-Gag, aber mittlerweile, glaube ich, muss man das echt ernst nehmen.
Ja, ja, also ich meine, vor allem, wenn man jetzt so ein Telefon von Grund auf neu entwickelt, dann ist es ja absolut einfach, so etwas mit zu berücksichtigen. Also natürlich der 0815-Telefon-Entwickler und der 0815-Telefon-User, der macht sich da keine Gedanken drüber. Aber wenn wir jetzt sozusagen als Leute mit diesem Bewusstsein ein Telefon von Grund auf neu entwickeln, dann passen wir natürlich auf, dass wir da solche Dinge ausschließen können. Dazu kommt, dass auch diese GPS-Einheit eine direkte Verbindung zum GSM-Teil hat. Das heißt, das geht auch wieder über diese Linux-konsolierte CPU. Das heißt, da gibt es keinerlei Möglichkeiten, dass Positionsdaten irgendwie direkt zum GSM kommen, ohne dass die freie Software dann beteiligt wäre. Darüber hinaus haben wir auch, wenn das Telefon ausgeliefert wird, IPSEC zum Beispiel drauf. Das heißt, man kann über das GPS Verschlüsselte IP Kommunikation haben.
Verschlüsselte TCP-IP Kommunikation, Internet-Kommunikation, wenn man es haben will. Und natürlich so VPN, Virtual Private Networks, Geschichten, ist alles kein großes Problem, so etwas zu installieren. Das wird wahrscheinlich auch von Anfang an in irgendeiner Form schon...
Na, IPSEC ist ja eine der VPN-Technologien. Auch OpenVPN, wenn wir auch...
Aber auch so ein Management-Interface, damit man so etwas leicht aufbauen kann, wäre natürlich sehr wünschenswert.
Das ist richtig, ist auch auf der Liste, ist natürlich von der Priorität her etwas untergeordnet.
Da sind wieder die Anwendungsentwickler gefragt.
Das ist richtig und da sind auch wieder Leute gefragt, die vielleicht mal irgendwie dem Projekt was beitragen möchten. Also wir konzentrieren uns natürlich jetzt im Moment auf die Core-Features, die wir brauchen. Also diese Dialer, die irgendwie einen tollen VPN-Konfigurationstool irgendwie schreiben will, dann ist das natürlich ein angesehenes Feature.
Viren und Würmer sind ja mittlerweile auch beim Mobiltelefon-Thema. Wie denkst du, wird sich das OpenMoko da beweisen können?
Na ja, zunächst sind wir halt eine Linux-Distribution wie jede andere auch. Das heißt, wir haben genau die gleichen Level an Verwundbarkeit wie jedes andere Linux-System. Wir haben ein Paketformat, also dieses IPK-Format. Das IPKG, das ist das Programm, das sozusagen diese Paketverwaltung macht, hat auch ähnlich wie Apt oder andere Tools im Linux-Bereich die Möglichkeit, eben Updates automatisch zu erkennen auf dem OpenMoko-Software und dann eben Paketupdates zu installieren.
Die dann aber auch entsprechend digital signiert sein können?
Ja, die werden signiert sein. Das sind sie im Moment noch nicht, aber das ist auf jeden Fall auf der Liste. Die Verwundbarkeiten beschränken sich ja im Wesentlichen auf die TCP-IP-Seite, weil ansonsten über das GSM ist da schon die Wahrscheinlichkeit äußerst gering, dass da irgendwas passieren kann, weil der ganze GSM-Teil läuft ja schädlich separat auf einem eigenen Prozessor mit anderem Betriebssystem. Und dass jemand sozusagen erst dieses System exploitet, um dann irgendwelche komisch gestrickten AT-Kommandos auf die Linux-Seite zu schicken und dann dort irgendwas zu exploiten, das ist dann schon irgendwie außerordentlich unwahrscheinlich. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen ausgeschlossen, aber das ist schon eine ganz andere Geschichte. Und gut, auf der TCP-IP-Seite, naja, wir haben da standardmäßig natürlich keine irgendwie offenen Dienste, abgesehen von SSH, offen. Das heißt, da gibt es jetzt keine Ahnung, Samba oder was auch immer auf dem Telefon oder keinen Apache. Das heißt, die Angriffspunkte sind da doch beschränkt auf der Ebene. Was dann E-Mails und dergleichen anbetrifft, naja, gut, sicherlich. Da ist dann halt die Frage, wie ist die Code-Qualität von den Bibliotheken?
Aber zumindest ist es halt ein offener Prozess an der Stelle.
Es ist ein offener Prozess. Es wird Security-Updates geben, wie bei jeder anderen guten Linux-Distribution. Wir haben überhaupt ein Betriebssystem, was zwischen unterschiedlichen Security-Levels differenziert. Unser User-Interface läuft ja auch nicht irgendwie mit System-Privilegien. Auch der GSM-Demon, der die Kommunikation mit dem GSM-Teil abliefert, läuft wieder als eigener User und so weiter.
Zum Schluss möchte ich noch mal auf einen Punkt kommen. Jetzt haben wir ja viel über Features geredet, die jedes Telefon hat oder vielleicht besser tun sollte. Es gibt ja eine Sache, die komplett abwesend ist. Das ist Kryptographie, also verschlüsselte Telefonkommunikation. Inwieweit habt ihr euch da schon Gedanken gemacht? Inwieweit lässt diese eingeschränkte Zugriff auf das GSM-Modul eine effektive Kryptographie überhaupt zu? Und ist da schon irgendwas am sich entwickeln?
Zunächst ist es für FIC oder OpenMoko aus Business-Aspekten aber auch jetzt natürlich kein unglaublich wichtiges Feature. Das heißt, ist ein Nice-to-have irgendwo auf der Liste. Nichts worauf wir jetzt unglaublich viel Zeit verwenden würden. Man hat prinzipiell die Schwierigkeit bei GSM, dass die Art und Weise, wie Sprachdatenverbindungen bei GSM gemacht werden, eigentlich keine Kryptographie zwischen Reihen schalten lassen. Die einzige Variante, wie man das machen kann, ist über Datenverbindungen. Das heißt, man macht dann sogenannte CSD, also Circuit Switch Data. Das ist so etwas wie eine Modemverbindung über GSM. Oder dann eben tatsächlich GPRS, also dann Voice-over-IP mit Datenpaketen. Das sind die zwei Varianten, wie man Kryptographie machen kann. Das liegt daran, dass der Umfang an Fehlerkorrektur und an Resistenz, was Paketverluste und Datenveränderungen auf dem Funkkanal betrifft, dass das einfach ganz unterschiedlich ist, ob da Daten- oder Sprachtelefonate geführt werden. Das heißt, egal, was für ein Level an Zugriff man auf das GSM-Modem hat, es ist einfach eine fundamentale technische Beschränkung. Man kann bei einer normalen GSM-Gesprächstelefonie keine Kryptographie zwischenschalten. Das halte ich für ausgeschlossen.
Im Prinzip auch genauso gut.
Das ist aber keine End-zu-End-Kryptographie. Das ist das große Problem. GSM hat unterschiedliche Cipher. Das, was für die Daten passiert, ist eine Verschlüsselung, die nur zwischen dem Mobiltelefon und der nächstgelegenen Basisstation passiert. Danach läuft das Ganze unverschlüsselt weiter. Eine End-zu-End-Geschichte würde auf einer anderen Ebene innerhalb des Photocode-Stacks liegen. Das verzweigt sich dann mit diesen Konfessions- und Fehlerkorrekturmechanismen nicht. Es ist auch so, dass die kommerziell verfügbaren Produkte im Bereich auch genau den gleichen Druck machen. Das heißt, sie machen eine Datenverbindung auf und nehmen dann einen beliebigen Voice-Codec, wie man für Voice-over-IP auch nimmt.
Aber sie haben dann halt immer dieses Delay mit drin. Also das wird man auch sehen. Es gibt ja auch diese Diskussion bei GSM-Telefonen. Die Kryptographie, also das Einschalten der Basisverschlüsselung von GSM, kann ja netzeitig quasi angefordert werden von dem Telefon, dass das ausgeschaltet werden soll.
Also unser GSM-Modul beherrscht die sogenannten Cyphering Indications. Das heißt, das GSM-Modul kann gegenüber dem Linux-Teil melden, ob Verschlüsselung an ist oder aus, und spezifikationsgemäß meldet es das auch. Es kann aber sein, dass der Mobilfunkanbieter bei Ausgabe der SIM-Karte auf der SIM-Karte hinterlegt, dass der GSM-Teil das unterdrücken soll. Das erfahren wir dann aber auch. Das heißt, ich kann das GSM-Modul fragen, zwingt dich die SIM-Karte dazu, uns zu sagen, dass du uns nicht mitteilst, wenn die Verschüsselung abgeschaltet wird? Und dann sagt das GSM-Modul eben, ja, sie zwingt mich, oder nein, sie zwingt mich nicht. Und also ich hab das hier mit meinen E-Plus-Karten, wo ich im Moment und Base meine Entwicklung betreibe, da funktioniert das mit den Cyphering Indications. Das heißt, ich bekomme nach der Netzregisterung mitgeteilt sowohl für GSM als auch für GPHS, dass die Verschüsselung an ist. Jetzt ist es natürlich eine Vertrauensfrage, kann man dem GSM-Modul da trauen, aber zumindest die GSM-Spezifikation fordert an, dass das gemacht werden muss und dass das auch so angezeigt werden muss. Es ist kein optionales Feature meines Wissens nach, das heißt eigentlich würde das Telefon nicht GSM-compliant sein und damit sozusagen nicht zulassungsfähig, wenn das nicht stimmt. Also ist die Frage, kann man da auch vertrauen oder nicht?
Aber in dem Moment, wo das Modul sich korrekt verhält, kann das Telefon auf jeden Fall diese Information zur Kenntnis nehmen und wird es dem auch sagen?
Ja, das gibt es in unserem Panel sozusagen, gibt es dann eine Doc-App in dem Panel drin, was das anzeigt.
Gut, ich würde sagen, jetzt haben wir das auch alles mal ganz gut abgedeckt, was es an Informationen gibt. Wer jetzt nach weiteren Informationen dürftet, der sollte marschieren zu openmoko.org.
Genau, openmoko.org ist das Portal, da kommt man dann aufs Wiki, auf unseren Backzilla, auf die Mailing-Listen und dergleichen. Und in Kürze wird es dann auch openmoko.com geben, das heißt die Seite, wo man Telefone kaufen kann.
Und diese Telefone kann man kaufen ab wann?
Ich würde mal sagen, erste Woche April ist ein realistischer Zeitpunkt, wo man Telefone im Direktkratzie bestellen kann, das heißt, man bestellt die über einen Webshop mit Kreditkarte oder ähnlichem und bekommt sie dann aus Taiwan zugeschickt. Der Zeitpunkt nach Roadmap, wann die Telefone auch über Großhändler und Einzelhandel im Computerbereich verfügbar sein sollen, ist September. Ob wir das halten können, weiß ich noch nicht.
Wird sich zeigen. Gut, das war Chaosradio Express 42. Vielen Dank Harald für die ausführliche Information zum Telefonprojekt OpenMoko. Können wir uns erstmal ordentlich verabschieden hier. Tschüss. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und alles weitere unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Und wenn ihr Anmerkungen zur Sendung habt, wie immer, chaosradio.ccc.de. Wir freuen uns auch über Feedback. Auf Wiedersehen!